apple is dang good at butchering
products but making them good enough to
sell and this one is selling like crazy
even though a lot of reviewers said that
you shouldn't buy it in this long-term
review I'm gonna be sharing the
surprises that we found both good and
bad and if you want to make a smarter
Choice what you should buy the iPad 10
is Apple's first redesign of the budget
iPad and I say redesign like this
because technically they still sell the
budget one at the same price and this
thing got a whole lot expensive and Tech
reviewers General consensus was that it
is overpriced but if we take a look at
Amazon sales the iPad 10 is in second
place only being beat by the 9th
generation cheaper model and beating out
even the cheap Amazon Fire tablets as
well as iPad Air 5 the iPad Mini the
iPad pros this thing is selling like
hotcakes and even though in my initial
review I said it should be priced at 399
dollars and I expected to drop there
shortly if we look it is still about 450
bucks including the silver the yellow
color and only the pink and blue ones
are discounted by ten dollars and thirty
dollars in a time when people are
stopping buying Tech products so why are
people buying a ton of these well I will
start with the positives the first thing
that stood out to me in this time is the
battery life now this thing has the A14
in it just like the iPad Air 4 but it is
actually down clocked if we look at the
performance with the same chip the same
style design it is significantly lower
and that is because Apple underclocked
it and that means when you are using it
it uses less power and that is something
that we noticed when we were using it
now the one and only on YouTube did I a
comparison of iPad battery life and in
standby time the iPad 10 killed it and
the same thing goes for multitasking
social media was better and at the end
the winner was the iPad 10. so that's
definitely a standout aspect of this
iPad now the other thing is the camera
layout it is the only iPad that has a
horizontal camera and that has been
great especially when you pair it with
their keyboard case or just the back
portion as a stand now my kids have been
loving using this iPad they use it for
pictures they use it for video this is
the one they want instead of the iPad
Mini or the previous iPad 9. having the
horizontal camera makes a huge
difference just look at this side by
side the quality is better it actually
looks like you're looking at whoever
you're FaceTiming with or if you're
recording yourself this is a major
selling point for a lot of people now
Apple put put this in for the iPad to
help itself but at the same time they
took away the apple pencil 2 that's
usually paired with this chassis likely
because that camera positioning and this
is just terrible because it is a pain
for my kids to charge that pencil
because we have a USB type-c port now
that little cap is lost so it's just a
really bad experience the adapter is not
included in the box which it should be
so that is one thing that we don't have
an issue with with the other iPads where
when my kids were using them they didn't
lose even the apple pencil because it
stays magnetically attached now the same
thing goes for the keyboard I like that
it detaches gives you a little bit more
flexibility you could use just the stand
but at this time I don't know where the
keyboard is because unlike the magic
keyboard that stays together once you
detach it set it down it's an issue
especially for kids the other thing is
the price at 250 bucks and without
having backlighting built in it is just
ridiculously expensive and the discounts
right now are barely there compared to
buying a refurbished magic keyboard for
145 bucks on Amazon right now with the
killer return policy and the same thing
goes for the iPad itself you guys saw
that the cheapest was 420 dollars but
did you know that for 418 you could buy
the iPad Air 4 that has the same A14 but
has more performance for 418 dollars
renewed three month return policy and
not only do you have the more powerful
version of the A14 you also have better
speakers you have a laminated display
which means that you have way less
reflectivity better Coatings better
blacks and contrast
overall that iPad is a lot better you
have apple pencil to support with
Magnetic charging you don't have to deal
with that cable by the adapter none of
that headache overall it is a much
better iPad other than that landscape
display and a lot of people just don't
know that I'll go ahead and Link that
down in the description below because it
just makes so much more sense but what a
lot of people do is they go into the
store go on Amazon see the new design
they see the price tag and they just buy
it because it's easy and it's there and
overall it's a good iPad but what kills
me is just the butchering of it they
made this thing thicker just to give it
a laminated display to set it apart they
took the USBC port in here they slowed
it down dramatically making it take much
longer to transfer files and having this
new flat side design just like the iPad
Air and the iPad Pro you would think
that it would work perfectly fine with
the magic keyboard just like the iPad
Air but even though it fits perfectly
with the magic keyboard it will not stay
there because Apple changed where the
magnets were at and I think that really
sucks because they made this thing
thicker they could have put a few extra
magnets in to be able to have it sit
here and then you would have the option
of both Styles but they don't and like I
mentioned the new 250 keyboard with the
folio one well it does not have a
backlit keyboard it is actually fairly
wobbly where the connection is the
magnets themselves are strong but it
moves all over the place that also means
when you close it it can rub side to
side it doesn't hold well magnetically
that can add to having scratches
and with that it also sucks that they
only offer it in white look how dirty
this thing is I don't even want to show
you guys a close-up of it my kids were
using it and it's disgusting the white
gets super dirty I have the white magic
keyboard for the 12.9 inch iPad it looks
nice but even using it mostly here at
the office keeping it super clean it
gets dirty and it sucks and I don't know
why they would do that so the iPad 10
would be a great iPad at a lower price
or if Apple just didn't limit it on
purpose to make it worse that screen
reflectivity for me is noticeable every
single time I turn the iPad on it just
looks worse than iPads that were out
five six years ago and that USB type-c
port they limited the charging speed as
well when it would work perfectly fine
charging faster so even though the
battery life is better it takes longer
to charge and that is where Apple on
purpose make an iPad worse just really
really bugs me and it makes me want an
updated iPad air but of course that
brings you up further in the latter to
spend more money and Apple's so good at
that where the base model comes in 64
gigs of storage and you got to pay a lot
more to upgrade at that point you might
as well buy an iPad Air but then you
also want to upgrade the storage and
then you're right there with the 11 inch
iPad and then at that point man I want
that mini LED so so it is just crazy it
is frustrating but people are still
buying these things so you guys let me
know your thoughts down in the comment
section Below have you bought one of
these what is your experience been like
maybe if you didn't watch this review
you would like it more without seeing
how much stuff Apple limited on purpose
or maybe you just don't really care go
ahead and click that Circle above to
subscribe check out our comparisons
right there we have a comparison with
the iPad Air with the budget iPad those
are very informative so check those out
it's been Max and I will see you guys in
the next video
[Music]
thank you